[MUSIC PLAYING]
EWA DUERR: Welcome to the
session on cloud automation
for Industrie 4.0.
My name is Ewa Dueer.
And I am a product obsolete for
Cloud AI EMEA Engineering team
in Munich.
One of Google's primary
goals is to democratize
AI and automation and make
it easy and accessible
for all industries.
Our vision is to
harness the power of AI
for the industry across
multiple verticals--
retail, logistics,
manufacturing, automotive,
and many others.
However, before we deep
dive into that vision,
I want to get us
started by looking
at the state of the
automation today.
Automation today it is
only economical at scale.
The upfront costs of
integration are huge,
and the results are inflexible
to changes in workflows.
However, there is a new
trend emerging on the market.
A new generation of
collaborative robots
are making the automation
much more affordable.
They are equipped with modern
sensors and software layers
that are easy to program.
This new generation
of robots are
useful in unpredictable
environments and work side
by side with humans.
We still have to tackle
a couple of challenges
before we can
leverage the benefits
of that new technology.
Firstly, the setup and
maintenance of robot fleets
today is typically
brought to the market
by system integrators that
create highly customized
solution to individual clients.
As a result, only large
industrial customers
can afford automation
and then mostly only
for highly repetitive tasks.
Secondly, given this
highly customized nature
of integration, there is
a strong vendor lock-in.
If you want to renew
your robot fleet
or use different type of
robots, setup and maintenance
becomes extremely complex.
Thirdly, most of the assets
used for automation use cases
are proprietary.
Thus, it is hard for
both software developers
and hardware manufacturers
to scale the applications.
And as a result, they are forced
to deploy bespoke solutions
for individual clients.
Last but not least,
most of the solutions
are deployed only on-premise,
which hinders scalability,
flexibility, and efficiency.
At Google Cloud,
we are dedicated
to handles those
challenges in order
to make automation easier
and more affordable.
Our cloud automation
platform provides
foundational
capabilities for cloud
enabled automation
solutions that
are scalable, support large
data volumes and speed,
flexible, allowing
flexible distribution
and deployment of
software assets,
and efficient, permit better
utilization and infrastructure
as a software provisioning.
Our cloud automation
solution allows
companies that are interested
in the promise of Industrie 4.0
to turn their operations into
the competitive advantage.
And the key word
here is flexibility,
that is the ability to
easily connect and operate
the fleet independently
of the vendor.
One key technology behind
that is Kubernetes,
which builds on years
of experience of Google
in automatic deploying and
scaling software assets.
We also address fundamental
security concepts,
such as authentication
and authorization.
We also facilitate reliable
connectivity and communication
with synchronous and
unsynchronous communication.
And last but not least, we
provide critical infrastructure
for sensor data
aggregation and processing
that builds on familiar
technologies, such as, Bigtable
BigQuery, and DataFlow.
As mentioned, the key technology
behind that is Kubernetes.
Using Kubernetes, we
enable the distribution
of containerized software assets
that can run on three tiers--
on robot, on-premise,
and in the cloud.
We use Kubernetes to enable
robot hardware abstraction
and command and control
that is tolerant
to intermittent connectivity.
With Kubernetes technology,
we also create the opportunity
for third party developers
to quickly engage
with our platform
and develop on that.
On top of that, we want to
enable the vision of what we
started calling digital twin.
This is the mirror
of the physical world
in the digital world.
Imagine the robot running
through that warehouse
and collecting the data
on inventory levels.
Exactly the same robot can run
through that warehouse and flag
damaged items, creating new
opportunities for quality
management and inventorization.
That is, digital twin
and AI capabilities
with perception-driven
capabilities
open the whole set
of new opportunities
that go much beyond automation.
Last but not least,
on top of this,
all this critical
infrastructure, we
want to offer first party
services that leverage cloud
automation platform
and solve critical pain
points for the clients.
The first one is
localization and mapping
that uses data from
sensors like [? gliders ?]
and depth cameras.
It allows robots
to create a map,
localize themselves on that map,
and recognize static landmarks.
With our spatial
intelligence service,
we further want to analyze that
sensor data and semantically
understands that environment,
direct robots to rows,
shelves instead of just
metric coordinates.
Last but not least, with our
object intelligence service,
we can use the same data
to discover and identify
important objects and their
location in the work space
that allows robots to
perform certain operations
on those items.
So how does all
that look in action?
The best early implementation
of that technology
is Bechtle Logistics.
That's where we
work with Bechtle,
SAP as a provider of
warehouse management system,
MIR, Mobile Industrial Robots,
the provider of hardware
a local robot fleet,
and Navvis, the enabler
of the digital twin.
But before I talk too
much about Bechtle,
I just want to invite Bechtle
itself on stage, Klaus Kratz,
the head of logistics
of Bechtle to tell you
about his experience and
how we are making impact
with our technology there.
Welcome.
Thank you very much.
KLAUS KRATZ: Thank you.
Ewa, thank you very much for
the introduction and having me.
I'm indeed very happy
to be in San Francisco.
As you have mentioned,
we are from Germany.
And Germany is the country of
the thinkers and the poets.
So why I should be here in this
incredible innovative place?
Because I have adapt
your mentality,
your spirit, the
American spirit just
to do whatever it takes
to gain new knowledge
and new competencies.
Also, that's why I'm
very enthusiastic to have
started this project with
Google, with Navvis, SAP,
and MIR.
At Bechtle, this
is our headquarter.
At Bechtle, I'm
responsible for logistics.
We sell hardware, software,
IT solutions, and IT services
and of course, cloud services.
We are a European company.
And we have partners
all over the world.
For example, PC Connection
in Massachusetts
is a partner of us in America.
We have more than
10,000 employees
and 17,000 happy customers.
Bechtle is, in my opinion,
a German success story,
not at the scale of
Google of course.
But we have tripled our revenues
within the last 10 years
from 1.8 billion euro
to 4.2 billion euro.
And our target is
for the next 10 years
to double again this
turnover to 10 billion euro.
To reach this target, we have
to integrate our customers more
deeply, increase efficiency,
flexibility, and quality
within our processes
and systems,
and find ways to cooperate
with future strategic partners.
When the wind of change
blows, some people,
they build walls, others,
they build windmills,
and we are building windmills.
So Bechtle Logistic has to
change from volume distribution
to solution distribution.
On this way, we
already provide value
added services, such
as individual tagging,
packaging, repackaging,
and transporting
and also sustainable solution.
Maybe in the near
future, we will
have a flat rate for
workplace, for all IT equipment
and software, customer needs,
including the recycling
and disposal of used hardware.
Currently, we have four main
warehouses-- the biggest
warehouses in Germany.
We have other warehouses
in France, Switzerland
and Netherlands.
In the past, we had to
optimize and physically
alter our warehouses,
which require
a lot of time and improvisation
skills and a lot of money,
as you can see within
the next photos.
And this is really reality.
So why we have this drilling
machine in our warehouse?
Because we had to implement a
mezzanine within our warehouse.
And we had to drill 30
holes 11 meters deep.
And this is really
logistical things.
It's really tough.
And we have done like
[? crystal ?] every night.
We have covered our racks to
avoid dust of all our articles.
And then you can
see the mezzanine.
It's 3 and 1/2
thousand square meters.
You see the white ellipse.
Behind this, there
are people working.
And an American
colleague said to me,
oh, this is very
bad, because it's
against security restrictions.
So I've hidden these
two people there.
But you can see a stage,
a mezzanine is growing.
And this is the
actual warehouse.
In the rack, we have big parts
like servers, PCs, notebooks.
And on the mezzanine,
in we have small parts
like cables and USB sticks.
In the future, we will need
many more warehouses in Germany
and also in Europe
with a possibility
to automate processes, adapt
them to customer requirements.
We need in the future
very high flexibility,
dynamic scalability, and
very short throughputs
to deliver to our customer
as fast as possible.
Our customers can count
on us for the support
they need to reach their own
targets as they transition
to German Industry 4.0.
The future warehouse,
in my opinion,
is a combination of
traditional technologies,
like high rack warehouse
systems and modern technologies,
or new technology like,
autonomous mobile robots.
In our warehouse,
as if I had said,
we have already implemented the
Google SAP MIR Navvis solution.
We are using the solution for
tasks such as cross-docking.
Cross-docking items means
that in inbound logistics,
we get information from SAP,
but customer orders have already
been placed for these items.
Instead of processing
put-away and picking,
we bring these items directly
to the outbound logistics.
In the past, we did this
with electrical vehicles
on a pallet.
And now we are doing it with
racks, multi-level racks
and the robotics.
And how it's working I
would show in a video.
So this is Claudio,
the MIR robot.
It's Claudio 1.
With the support of
its sensors, Claudio
picks up the cart on which
are cross-docking items.
Claudio starts to
drive autonomously
to its designated destination.
And Claudio drives
within a defined zone
and avoids barriers that may
occur on its way independently
by going around them.
Claudio observes
the environment.
Still, our people have
got to get used to it.
In some critical areas with
cross traffic or forklifts,
Claudio is emitting
sounds to get attention.
Claudio transports the cart
to its designated destination
and moves out for new tasks.
It's great.
And this is a great team from
Google, SAP, and Bechtle.
As a result of using
autonomous mobile robots
and future optimization, we can
achieve flexible automation,
process optimization,
scalability, and productivity.
And I had a good example
from a forklift driver,
because we are very
transparent and if we
change to such new technologies,
we have an open communication,
we speak with other people
and to persuade them
because we have an unemployment
rate of 2% in the region
I am working.
So we have to be forced
automize our warehouses,
because we don't
get any more people.
We have to qualify them.
And so the people have
realized that this is possible.
And they are not afraid.
And the forklift
driver, the next day, I
have mentioned that we
go in this strategy.
He said to me,
but Mr. Kratz, you
have to pay attention
with the robotics,
because I don't
want to crash them
So people immediately
think about--
and this is great
in my opinion--
what will happen with
these new technologies?
And this is also the
adaption of the people
for these new technologies.
So thank you very much
for your attention.
And if you are ever
in Germany, feel
free to come by and say hello.
[APPLAUSE]
EWA DUERR: Thank you
very much, Klaus,
for bringing your valuable
perspective to that audience
and sharing your experiences
with our project.
Thank you.
We'll continue.
This is exactly the
best implementation
of how we and our
partners, such as MIR,
and Navvis, and SAP can make
an impact for businesses
like Bechtle.
In particular, we
need to make sure
that we make automation
drastically simpler
and less expensive.
Our core value
proposition thus has
to be flexible automation with
collaborative for robots that
can seamlessly and gradually
be deployed into the existing
environment as needed.
Secondly, we need to escape
the vendor lock-in trap
and enable an easy deployment
of heterogeneous fleet
that are vendor agnostic.
Clients like Bechtle
shouldn't have
to take care of
coordinating the robots
and processes between
different kinds of robots.
Rather, we should enable an
ERP system the assignment
of tasks and orders in
an intelligent manner
across various robots.
Thirdly, we now have a
chance to grow our impact
by shaping new opportunities in
analytics, for example, quality
management, inventorization,
space management, and so
on and so forth.
By putting our AI
capabilities into action,
we will enable the
vision of digital twin,
generating new insights that
go much beyond pure automation.
Finally, we need to break away
from purely on-prem solutions
that are difficult
to scale and suffer
from limited flexibility in
low resource utilization.
Rather, cloud automation
should use Kubernetes
to enable easy deployment
and distribution
of containerized
software assets that
can run on-robot,
on-premise and in the cloud.
With all that, we can
generate real business impact
that allows fast
and easy automation
and enables the flexibility
in setting up and maintaining
automation processes.
It facilitates efficiency
and increased utilization
by efficient fleet management,
better and faster localization,
and optimized path planning.
It also triggers
productivity improvements
by turning analytics into action
and opening new opportunities
in inventory space and
quality management.
And last but not least, it
provides basis for scalability,
competitiveness, and
better customer service
that will allow businesses
to reap new revenue sources
and engage with new clients.
But to enable all that vision
and leverage that technology,
we need to work
with our partners
and grow that platform
into an ecosystem
where each of the participants
can benefit and contribute,
providing their
complementary skills.
That's why we
invited some of them
today to share their experiences
with Cloud Automation Platform
and explain to you how we
can all create new business
opportunities for them.
And on that note, I want to
invite on stage our partners.
Nemrude Verzano, head
of Industry 4.0 at SAP,
he leads innovation
projects in the areas
of logistics, manufacturing,
and retail and drives
programs for the intelligent
enterprise strategy for SAP.
Thank you very much
for being here.
Walk on stage.
[APPLAUSE]
We also will have Niels
Jacobsen, co-founder
and CSO of MIR, Mobile
Industrial Robots,
one of the largest
collaborative robotics
manufacturers in the world.
Thank you for coming.
[APPLAUSE]
Then we have Felix
Reinshagen, co-founder
and CEO of Navvis, a powerful
platform for the digital twin
for indoor applications.
Thank you very much for
flying over to San Francisco.
And last but not least,
we have Moritz Tenorth,
CTO of Magazino, that builds
and develops intelligence
collaborative robots
for internal logistics
with particular focus on
mobile picking robots.
Thank you very much.
We have one chair too much.
Thanks, you guys, hope
you had a good trip.
Thanks for coming here and
sharing your experiences
to that audience on the
cloud automation platform.
I want to get us started by
asking the same question to all
of you.
Please explain how are
your companies benefiting
from the Cloud
Automation Platform.
What are the key challenges that
you're facing at this stage,
and what are the benefits that
you are drawing from working
together in that ecosystem?
And maybe let's get
started with MIR,
getting from the bottom of this
[? talk, ?] from the hardware.
NIELS JACOBSEN: I can say
that at MIR, we develop
and manufacture what we
call Autonomous Mobile
Robots, or AMR.
And we do that for
indoor transportation
to help the logistic there,
to optimize logistic and also,
as we heard before, actually to
free some of the working force
there.
So some of the
challenges we see there,
as you have already
mentioned actually,
is the cost of integration.
We are distributing
all our robots
through a network
of integrators.
And they are taking the
robot to the end users,
integrating that
for that purpose.
And it still takes a lot
of time and is costly,
even though we have a simple
system to operate on there.
And then you can also say that
sometimes that the customer,
there always are a new way
of using the robots that they
would like.
And that is always
something that you not
can provide out of the box.
Then the customer
has to wait-- either
for a software
upgrade from our side
or find another
solution for that.
And then we have the last
[? modern ?] [? stength ?] is
the integration with ERP or
warehouse management system
there.
We also see that there tends
to be a lot of specialized
software there.
And here we really see
that this cloud solution
can go in and help us on
many of the points there.
This ability to have
versioning and updating
of the system, more
or less for free.
We also see that with
a cloud platform,
the ability to have
data aggregated
to the cloud in a way
that you can do analysis
is now possible on
a much larger scale.
And also the ability
to have add-in
[? plugs, ?] like
an SAP integration,
can be of great help for us.
EWA DUERR: You mentioned
SAP and the integration
with the ERP system.
What is SAP saying on that?
What are the key challenges
that you are facing?
And building on that point,
exactly how are you benefiting
from working with
us, and with Niels,
and all the other partners?
Rudy?
NEMRUDE VERZANO:
Yeah, the thing is
that SAP has a lot of
customers-- not only
in a [INAUDIBLE]
management environment.
And more and more
of our customers
are interested in making
use of collaborative robots.
And the thing is, usually,
also our customers
have different kinds of
specific processes they
want to have be customized
depending on which areas
they are-- like mining,
manufacturing, discrete
and processing
industries, or logistics.
The thing, of course, is that,
looking at those devices--
those robots-- they
have different kinds
of capabilities.
Compared to static robots,
they can be trained.
They can repeat their
processes over and over again.
Why you have seen it on the
pictures-- on the video--
that they have
more capabilities,
more dynamic features that
need to be considered.
So in our case, we cannot
really cover everything.
And therefore, we need a
kind of flexible environment
where we can also integrate
to customers, partners,
and third-party
solutions easily.
And that's what the
Cloud Robotics Platform
will help us to cope with
all kinds of challenges
that are related to
collaborative robots
in this case.
Just as an example,
if [INAUDIBLE]
is going to make use
of further fleets
that are not from
MIR or from Magazino,
then the challenge will
be to orchestrate them.
OK?
And to orchestrate
them is one thing.
But to assign the tasks from
the back end accordingly
will be the next thing.
But to do it over and over
again for every customer
would not make sense at all.
So we will be
definitely benefiting
from this Cloud
Robotics initiative
to plug-in existing solutions--
even custom-developed solutions
for specific customers.
And we can deploy
them easily regardless
if that component is being
deployed on the robot,
on the cloud, on-prem depending
on the use case of course.
And we will definitely
be more flexible
than we were in the past.
We'll integrate all
kinds of devices.
That is our point.
EWA DUERR: Building on
the point of both Niels--
and Rudy mentioned cloud--
Felix, you are gathering
with [? enabler ?]
of the digital
twin-- a lot of data.
How are you benefiting
from the cloud
and from the Cloud Automation
Platform at this stage?
FELIX REINSHAGEN:
First, let me say
a few words on what
we are doing at Navvis
because this whole
term of digital twin
is gaining a lot of momentum.
And I think it still needs
a little bit of explanation.
So what we are doing is we
do not model environment,
but we scan environment.
And we scan it on
mobile devices--
think about the mini
version of the famous Google
Car, now capable of
working without GPS
and equipped scanners,
with cameras.
And it creates super
dense and detailed 3D maps
of its environment that we then
overlay with more information
and make walkable digital
twins out of that that you
can access in your browser.
And that's the point.
Today, we are creating already
digital twins of manufacturing
facilities for a lot of the
largest automotive companies
in the world.
But the data is being created
and processed in a form
that it's most catering
towards human beings--
for space optimization,
logistics optimization.
However, of course,
we want to make
this data accessible for
our clients in a much more
flexible way.
And we believe
that, in the future,
this data will perhaps
even be used by more
robots than human beings.
And then, all the
points come into play
that you mentioned before.
There will be very
different kinds of robots.
And they all need to be
capable of accessing,
not only our data,
but potentially,
as well, other model data.
So at the end, we
need good automation.
We need standardized
interfaces that
allow for a variety
of different robots,
as well as software solutions
to make use of this data.
That will make our clients
happy and, of course,
will drive the adoption
of what we are doing.
So that's why we're here.
EWA DUERR: Yeah, and
building on that, Moritz,
you are not only building
hardware, but also software.
What are the key challenges
that you are facing?
And how is Cloud
helping you do that?
MORITZ TENORTH: Yeah,
so with our company,
we're building the hardware,
but especially all the software
in the cloud integration for
mobile robots that not only
navigate and transport,
but also pick.
And these robots can
operate alongside the humans
in these same environments.
So they can drive through the
warehouses, identify the items,
pick from the shelves,
stow into the shelves,
and, basically, do all
of this in a shared
environment with
humans that pick
the same items from the
same shelves and so on.
And especially this
collaboration with humans
creates lots of challenges.
Because humans change
the world, and compared
to a classical
robots that really
like it when everything is
deterministic and predefined,
we live in a pretty
uncertain world.
We're still in a warehouse.
We're not in a children's
room in the afternoon.
That is much more
uncertain probably,
but the world is
changing constantly.
And the big challenge is
how do you, on the one hand,
design software
that scalable, that
is capable of analyzing
this data, that can
perceive the world into and
devise the right actions
from that?
How do you develop and
deploy this software
to a fleet of robots that are
somewhere in the warehouses?
But the big challenge,
I think, that we're
sharing with other people
dealing with autonomous robots
is basically how to
make them more robust--
so how to make it resilient
to changes, to perturbations,
to all kinds of changes that
the robots have to cope with.
And that's a pretty
data-driven thing.
So the developers don't
sit next to the robots.
They don't see what happened.
So you really need to
transfer all this context--
all this information-- from
the robots to the developers
or to your machine
learning algorithms.
And that's something
where we can really
benefit from the cloud I think.
On the one hand, for using
computation in the cloud--
on the other hand also
for using data storage.
So how can we stream the data?
I'm going to make it
available for easy
debugging-- also make it
available for automated machine
learning on that.
And another track is definitely
how can we use Cloud technology
in order to deploy
software on the robots
on the on-premise service
and the cloud service.
And for example, with
the Cloud Engine,
how do we deploy applications
on all of these different layers
at the same time?
How do we roll it
back and forth?
So that's super useful for us.
EWA DUERR: OK, and that's
definitely the key point here
is the integration between
the hardware and the software.
And coming back to the
hardware once more,
Niels, how do you see the future
for collaborative robotics?
And how can this open platform
and open ecosystem can help you
grow the market in the future?
NIELS JACOBSEN: You
can say, in a way,
we've already seen
with our mobile robot
that there's a
whole community now,
building what we
call top modules.
So that is different platforms
you put on top of robots.
And--
EWA DUERR: We've seen
that in the video as well.
NIELS JACOBSEN: But it's
still limited in a way,
because we cannot add new
software to it in an easy way.
So it's my hope that
we, in this way,
can envision what actually is
becoming a community that can
provide new solutions for us--
not only on the
hardware, but also
the capability of moving
the robot in another way.
We can have someone following
people knowing what to do.
And this can actually be a
business where these software
companies are [? leaving ?]
from just creating
this additional toolset for
different kinds of vendors.
We see that as a hope for that,
because we have many ones today
that want to build more
really good solutions,
but are just too small
of companies for that
because this environment
is just too spread.
Then you also see this ability
to move a lot of the computing
from the robot into the cloud.
EWA DUERR: Hmm.
NIELS JACOBSEN: It's
something we have been
hoping for more than 10 years.
But now we think that
the foundation now
is more or less ready.
So we can see the
first thing there.
Things like a planning
how the robot is moving
from in the warehouse there.
Of course, a robot on
their own can do that.
But now we have several hundreds
of robots moving together--
how this orchestration, as
we talked on before, how that
can be done.
That just makes a demand for
much more computing power.
That shouldn't be
on the robot there,
but should be on some kind
of cloud computing platform.
And last, [INAUDIBLE] we just
released our first AI product
this week.
So AI is really coming
onto the robots there,
but we'll see much more of that.
This is really a field that's
moving very, very fast.
And I don't think any
vendor can sit down and say,
we can do it the best.
We need to be open and see
what others can come up with.
And we really feel-- and also
some of the things you have
presented this week here--
that these are really,
really good platforms
on how the robots
can learn to interact
much more with the people.
So we really hope that the
cloud robotics platform will
be the right tool for that.
EWA DUERR: So enabling
the deployment
and the distribution of new
services-- new applications.
Moritz, you mentioned you are
building a lot of software
for your robots and
for your hardware.
How will that help you in
deployment and distribution?
It that the Kubernetes that is--
MORITZ TENORTH:
Yeah, I think it's--
EWA DUERR: --technology here?
MORITZ TENORTH: So Kubernetes,
at the different layers,
really promises to
facilitate this--
the whole DevOps
tasks that you have
to do on many robots
that are in the fields
with different internet
connectivity levels,
also having to some
on-premise installations
some cloud
installations, and so on.
And that can be
[? pretty ?] challenging
if you have large fleets--
also different hardware.
So it's not all virtualized.
You really have physical
devices behind that that are
mechanically different there.
And really deploying to
these things, managing them,
having the fleets
and data management--
I think that is one big thing
that we can benefit from.
Another one is to
really use the cloud
capabilities for making these
robots more intelligent, more
robust.
So doing more machine
learning in the cloud,
but also using existing
services from the cloud
and integrating
them more easily.
And I think third part
is what's also planned
for the robotic platform
to have the market
place so that we can
benefit from other people's
components--
for example, the localization
component, also some image
recognition, or parts.
But we can also use it for
sharing our own applications
with others.
So if other robot vendors
can use certain controller
components, for
example, that we have
a way of sharing that and
also sharing the experiences
we made there on solving
these real-world problems.
EWA DUERR: And building on
the application marketplace,
what are the benefits
in the future for you,
Felix, and for Navvis, as you
engage on that marketplace
and in that ecosystem?
FELIX REINSHAGEN: So
just give an impression
on what we create-- it's
layers and layers of data.
It starts as really
the replication
of the physical reality and
point clouds and images that
then transform into 3D models.
And each step, it's
kind of a data refinery.
It puts layers and
layers of data.
Like you started
with raw oil and end
up with all the different
plastics products.
And of course, on all
these different stages,
you have a very complex
processing-- a lot
of machine learning and AI.
A lot of that, we do ourselves.
But you are spreading
yourself very thin
if you're trying to do
all of that yourself.
And as well, all these
intermediate products
are very important
raw material, so
to say, for a lot of
other applications.
And on all these
different layers,
you encounter the problem
of standardizations
and interfacing.
And of course, we are talking
about vast amounts of data.
We are, by now, scanning
tens of millions
of square feet of data
every single month.
Some of our clients,
with hundreds
of millions of square
feet of industrial space,
now moved from scanning,
perhaps once every six months,
to every month.
And in the future, they
want to scan every day.
So they want to have something
like a real-time digital twin.
Only a very scalable and
robust cloud platform
can actually handle
this kind of data--
run continuously
through all these stages
of data processing.
So it's a matter of
scalability, absolutely.
It's a matter of
interoperability
with all the different players.
And of course, I think at the
end, you need a marketplace.
Of course, it will be myriads
of different applications
that do this data refinement
and, as well, take that data
and move it on
each of the layers
between different applications.
So yeah, I think that
is why we believe
that cloud-- or a large-scale
automated robotic platforms--
will play such an
important role for us.
And I think it's not even
possible to move that kind
of ecosystem forward without.
EWA DUERR: And coming
back to SAP-- and to Rudy,
maybe-- and building on
that point of creating
the marketplace and leveraging
different applications
for the business processes,
how are ERP systems
and SAP dealing with that
and benefiting from that?
And also, SAP and Google have a
broader strategic partnership,
so how does this project fit
into the overall relationship
and partnership
between Google and SAP?
Maybe you can comment on that.
NEMRUDE VERZANO: I think this
project has already proven
that the combined setup--
having Google as a kind
of infrastructure provider
to us in this robotics project--
and us being able to
concentrate on the business
processes only
allowed us then indeed
to ignore all this
communication, data storage,
and data management-- or
device management stuff--
that all of you, of course,
need to take care of.
But it allowed us
to concentrate--
to keep the core focus--
on the improvements of things
that we want to extend.
In our case, to get the
warehouse management
being connected to the
robots very easily.
And that we can
use infrastructures
that are easy to integrate--
also to deploy the different
components and containers
very easily.
And that we can identify easily
which components are used
for the specific use cases.
This allows us, of
course, on our journey
to support our
customers regarding
the intelligent enterprises
that most of our customers
are up to.
Also to include
further capabilities
that the Google Cloud
Platform is providing.
As you could see, on
the videos, for example,
the machine learning-based
vision service that Google is
providing--
we can integrate
easily into scenarios
and use cases without having two
weeks or two months of customer
development.
That will definitely
be of very big benefit
to many of our customers if they
want it to include and enhance
their processes.
And usually any
customer that we have
is somewhat interested in
integrating more and more
of the AI and ML capabilities.
So at the moment, we can
start with the foundation
that we have already in place.
But depending on the
use case the customer
is interested in, we can
pick different components
that are, for
example, on the Cloud
Platform, or our customer, or
even our partner is providing
and integrate it into
the process very easily.
And compared to former times, it
is by far easier now to do so.
And especially also in
conjunction with the Industry
4.0 initiative in Germany
that I'm also driving,
our goal is to have an
environment where we can do
plug-and-play of devices--
of robots-- that our
customers can easily
integrate the devices in their
processes in their business,
but also make use of
intelligence services
that can be coming, of
course, from Google,
from the Google Cloud
Platform, but also
from embedded
business applications
that we already have in place.
So therefore, it is definitely
a complementary setup
to enable our customers
accomplishing the goal
to have an intelligent
enterprise in the near future.
EWA DUERR: OK, and
definitely Google
is, as well, on
the positive note,
benefiting from the
partnership with SAP
with the business knowledge
in the B2B applications.
So I think we all can
benefit from that.
And since we are
running out of time,
I don't think there
is a better way
to end that panel
than just by saying
that we, as Google, are only as
successful as our partners are.
So we are happy that you
are happy, so to speak.
And for our clients, like
Bechtle, we definitely
want to drive business impact,
drive efficiency, scalability,
flexibility for our
partners, whether they
are startups, developers, ERP
providers, and so on and so
forth.
We definitely want to enable
new business opportunities
and enable you to reap
new revenue sources
and grow the market reach.
So that's our common goal,
I think, for all of us.
So on that positive
note, thank you
very much for your attention.
And feel free to reach out
to us after the session
if you have any questions.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
[MUSIC PLAYING]